Scorn is a game designed to frighten you.
It depicts a biomechanical nightmare
a fever dream where everything you see is a
shocking amalgamation of metal and meat. Yet
under the foreboding surface, the world of
Scorn is a masterpiece of haunting and poignant
worldbuilding, bringing to life a fascinating
ecosystem of flesh and decay. While the game
is ambiguous by design — lacking any text
or dialogue — a surprising number of answers
are waiting for those willing to look for
them. So, for this entry into the Archive,
we’ll embark on an expedition across this
disturbing realm, comparing environmental
details with clues from the artbook to uncover
the shocking secrets behind the terrors on
screen. Now, let’s awaken to the nightmare
of Scorn… We’ll begin with a birth. The
humanoid creatures of the Scorn universe aren’t
born from a nurturing parent, but burst fully
grown from an unnatural wall, and then plummet
to the ground, where many of their stories
end as abruptly as they began. The humanoid
protagonist you play as for most of the game
comes into the world from this unfeeling system.
After hitting the ground, it’s hard not
to stare up at the rows and rows of ruptured
cocoons and think about what it would be like
if this was the first thing you ever saw.
This immense structure, referred to in the
artbook as the Genesis Wall, is one of the
most striking concepts in the world of Scorn.
Dried husks lie beneath the embankment — humanoids
who perished through no fault of their own.
There’s a profound unfairness at play that
echoes the arbitrary nature of life, one of
the game’s core themes. Like many things
in Scorn, the wall seems both artificial and
biological, as there are places where the
outer layer falls away to reveal a mass of
living organs. While the design of the Genesis
Wall was conceived through stunning concept
art, where the wall came from is one question
the game’s developer, Ebb Software, declines
to answer. The wall simply is — a fact as
immutable as existence itself. Beyond the
wall’s shadow, a desolate wasteland greets
newborn humanoids as they take their first
steps. Called ‘The Field,’ this is a kingdom
of dust and ruin — a barren land seemingly
stripped of all natural resources. Through
the fog, the forms of distant buildings reveal
themselves — wind-worn structures silently
decomposing like the carcasses of gargantuan
animals. These haunting vistas conjure the
imagery of decaying ships present in sci-fi
horror films like Alien and Prometheus. The
late Swiss artist H. R. Giger, who worked
on the biomechanical designs for the original
Alien film, was a notable influence on the
world of Scorn. Some of the decaying ruins
form vaguely organic archways, which serve
as a subtle way to pull players onwards. One
of these thresholds leads to a cemetery of
machines, where industrial vents mark the
landscape like solemn gravestones. At a glance,
this industrial mausoleum seems as barren
as the rest of The Field. Yet defying all
odds, a strange form of life takes shelter
among the headstones. Seemingly originating
all the way back at the Genesis Wall, red
tendrils spread across the wastes like an
insidious infection, and like hermit crabs
seeking a shell, some masses of tentacles
have come to make their home within the vents.
These parasitic grows are all that can survive
this unforgiving climate. To the side of the
cemetery, the largest building in the region
is a monolithic structure called The Assembly.
The last bastion of shelter in a ruined land,
many forms of life make their home within.
Entering The Assembly is like exploring the
body of a long-dead giant. The hallways and
cavernous chambers call to mind fossilized
organs, with the ribbed pattern on the walls
unmistakably organic. This biomechanical interior
design once again evokes the spirit of Giger’s
work in the Alien franchise, where even buildings
take on the qualities of living things. While
the bodily systems of The Assembly have long
lain dormant, you can guide the playable humanoid
to reawaken the decrepit technology. But be
aware: Interacting with technology in Scorn
is never pleasant. Buttons and switches are
fleshy and bizarre, to the point where something
as simple as calling an elevator is vaguely
unsettling. And the more you explore and interact
with the interior, the more the original purpose
of The Assembly becomes apparent. The entire
labyrinthine structure functions as a kind
of factory. Enormous retro-industrial cranes
are positioned to move cargo, their articulated
hooks still sharp enough to be menacing. Spine-like
railways snake through The Assembly, implying
transport carts once rattled through this
area. An elevated control panel provides access
to a manipulatory claw-arm — like the world’s
largest and most disturbing arcade machine.
Yet a question remains: just what was this
factory processing? The answer is the last
available resource in the world of Scorn:
living things. At the base of this world’s
biomechanical ecosystem are the tragic Moldmen.
These pitiable lifeforms are the biomass The
Assembly is designed to produce, and are grown
within hard shells. Heaps of Moldmen husks
have been swept away into the corners of the
Assembly, with the size of these piles giving
us some glimpse of the scale of this factory’s
inhumanity when it was in full production.
The visuals of the Moldmen are evocative of
the work of Polish artist Zdzisław Beksiński,
a painter who explored themes of entropy and
decay. Beksiński’s art was a key influence
on the look of the game, with its emphasis
on somber visions of dried, calcified husks.
The imagery of a Moldman sitting in a transport
chair with their limbs extending out from
the shell also calls to mind the famous Giger
portrait of the Space Jockey. This ambiguous
visual of a being seemingly fused with a chair,
which was brought to life in the Alien franchise,
was a key influence in Scorn’s development.
According to concept artist Filip Acovic,
the team found inspiration not just in how
the design merged technology and living tissue,
but also in its mysterious nature. In the
original Alien film, next to nothing is revealed
about the strange being, and that uncertainty
encourages the viewer to reflect on the visual.
Likewise, much about the Moldmen and their
connection to The Assembly’s creators is
left an intriguing mystery. Deeper within
The Assembly, monolithic towers of tissue
grow in temperature-controlled, greenhouse-like
chambers. Like so many things in Scorn, the
purpose of these looming structures is left
ambiguous, with the mystery gnawing at the
back of the players’ mind as they walk in
their shadow. A melting pattern of what appears
to be calcified bone encircles the tops of
these columns, suggesting they produce organic
material used elsewhere in the factory. A
legion of flying drones tends to the tissue
towers’ every need, hydrating the chamber
like devoted gardeners. Each drone can release
a steady spray of chemical mist, which is
noxious to breath in, but seemingly critical
for the growth of the columns. Light from
the drones’ glowing, bulbous shells cuts
through the gloom, bathing the chamber in
an eerie glow. Like dutiful worker bees, the
drones stay fixed on their role in this biomechanical
ecosystem, never reacting to anything that
passes by. In the epicenter of the greenhouse,
the tissue towers are overshadowed by a sinister
central tree. This massive organism is far
larger than anything else in the region, and
appears to be the parent of the unsettling
forest that grows around it. A unique type
of carrier drone tends to this goliath, taking
vials of the fertilizing chemical and plugging
them directly into the tree. Yet these chemicals
aren’t the only fuel source in The Assembly.
Even deeper within the facility, a strange
structure with branching pods seems to supply
energy. Activating this device will cause
the pods to open in petal-like arrangements,
revealing humanoids kept in suspended animation
inside. These humanoids are closer to the
player’s character than the Moldmen, and
call to mind the living batteries seen in
the dystopian future in films like The Matrix.
The more you explore the lower levels of The
Assembly, the more the interiors become increasingly
organ-like. Extendable bridges link up sections
like valves in a heart. Tubes twist through
the region like veins — and some literally
seem to be veins. A corrosive substance analogous
to stomach acid clears up obstructions. Interacting
with these systems requires the continued
use of technology. Scorn does include some
traditional video game items like keys and
weapons, but filtered through a biomechanical
lens they become unrecognizable. A device
that opens doors looks like a fleshy worm.
A key that you pick up elsewhere in the game
resembles ringed vertebrae — making it a
literal skeleton key. To reload your main
weapon, you approach this nightmarish machine,
which loads bug-like ammunition into a living
starfish-satchel. Thematically, these visually
disquieting interactions seem to examine the
relationship between humanity and technology.
Exploring the intersection of the organic
and inorganic is a theme that’s unsurprisingly
central to the biomechanical art movement.
Returning once again to Giger, while it’s
easy just to focus on the cool-looking surface
imagery, much of Giger’s work is meant to
interrogate whether humans are losing themselves
to technology. It’s a question that in the
modern age only grows more and more urgent,
as opportunities to interface with,--and disappear
into-- technology become increasingly prevalent.
Likewise, in Scorn, the playable character
themselves is changed over the course of the
game. At various points in the early chapters,
the player can spot a strange creature scuttling
like a lizard along the walls. Called ‘The
Parasite,’ this lifeform eventually merges
with the protagonist, providing them with
useful abilities but slowly taking over their
body. To complicate this theme, the parasite
is themselves a warped humanoid who, after
having been exposed to mysterious chemicals,
has lost their identity, with various subtle
hints indicating they’re the humanoid the
player takes control of during the game’s
prologue. While most of Scorn explores how
machinery can assimilate the organic, the
parasite storyline seems to explore autonomy
from a different perspective, asking where
one identity ends and another begins. Near
The Assembly lies a gaping abyss known as
The Crater. A forgotten void, the depths of
The Crater are home to far more dangerous
forms of life. Presiding over this nightmarish
domain is a gargantuan, nameless monarch.
Larger than a building, the creature acts
as an insect queen to the life that infects
The Crater, constantly producing new forms
of workers. These smaller, more animalistic
terrors patrol the corridors surrounding The
Crater, and take on a variety of shambling
forms. According to game director Ljubomir
Peklar, these beings are made from the same
genetic material, but undergo rapid evolutionary
changes, resulting in distorted monstrosities
with occasionally recognizable animal features.
In some areas, flying creatures have evolved,
flitting about the corners of the player’s
vision, menacing you from a distance. All
these creatures serve the monarch at The Crater’s
center, and will rush to their defense if
they are harmed. And most every member of
the brood is dangerous, with the largest creatures
worth avoiding at all costs. Like snails leaving
a trail of slime, the creatures of The Crater
leave behind twisting masses of red tendrils.
These tentacles ungulate slowly, and seem
to be turning the atmosphere of The Crater
into something more comfortable for the brood.
In some places, this malignant infection has
become as dense as a rainforest, as if an
entirely new ecosystem is emerging in these
cavernous depths. In the distance, a vast
rail line promises a path away from this vile
land. If you reach the station, the tracks
run for many miles. But eventually, the railway
takes you to Scorn’s final destination — the
empty city of Polis. At a glance, Polis seems
entirely unlike other regions, with clean
walls and elegant, sculptural architecture.
Yet the more of this abandoned city the player
explores, the more you notice the darkness
that dwells under the surface. Inside the
central building, impossibly ornate murals
depict unsettling scenes with reverent detail.
These twisted tableaus show humanoids being
turned into something else. The citizens of
Polis seemed to worship transcendence from
a corporeal form, with the destruction of
‘self’ an ever-present theme. In this
regard, Scorn evokes the work of Giger a final
time — as he was known for making similar
murals. In the epicenter of the room, a bronze
automaton beckons to the sky. Above the statue’s
head, the vaulted ceiling is covered in an
immense network of neuron-like strings of
tissue. Given all we have seen, it appears
likely that the vanished citizens of Polis
live within this network, having abandoned
their physical bodies in favor of a mental
collective. What it is like to be part of
this collective is an open question, for those
within no longer have the means to answer.
Yet this city is not completely empty. Locked
away in jars are the pale, diminutive Homunculi,
artificial beings who appear to serve as living
batteries. Like many lifeforms in Scorn, these
creatures were created as a living resource,
their only individuality determined by the
shape of their jars. Yet Homunculi are quite
intelligent, able to create and interface
with cybernetic bodies to overcome their physical
confines. While in-game you don’t encounter
these creatures much outside the rare boss
fight, concept art shows their resourcefulness,
depicting them assembling cyborgs like car
mechanics in a garage. Although not cited
as a direct influence, many aspects of Scorn’s
worldbuilding evoke the demonic realm depicted
in Barlowe’s Inferno. An artbook by the
legendary Wayne Barlowe, Barlowe’s Inferno
envisions an infernal afterlife where all
the souls and bodies of inhabitants are a
resource used by a diabolical ruling class.
While visually the two works are in many ways
distinct, the worlds possess intriguing thematic
parallels. Whether or not the nightmarish
realm of Scorn is a literal hell is largely
left up to interpretation. But if a land is
so bleak that it’s impossible to distinguish
from a plane of eternal torment, there’s
an argument to be made that, on some level,
the distinction ceases to matter… But perhaps
there is salvation in the world of Scorn.
In the back of the central building, behind
a far more biological-looking mural, a door
opens up to a long walkway. At the end of
this path is a swirling matrix of energy that
seems to offer a form of transcendence. Before
the threshold of the nexus, statues of humanoids
melt into dreamlike strands, indicating what
will happen if you step inside. Perhaps entering
this matrix is a way to enter the collective
the citizens of Polis seem to have joined,
or perhaps it’s something else entirely.
In any case, it’s implied that converging
with this nexus — whatever it truly is — would
mean complete annihilation, the total loss
of one’s self. Is this really salvation,
or just another form of destruction? I certainly
won’t give away the ending to Scorn in this
video, but suffice to say, the game never
turns its back on the exceedingly bleak atmosphere
it’s so carefully crafted throughout its
storyline. The world that Scorn builds is
a grim, disturbing land of ceaseless torment.
There’s a lot of unsettling imagery in this
game, much more than I’ve shown on screen
here, so be aware of that if you plan to check
it out for yourself. Yet the world of Scorn,
for all its alien qualities, is undeniably
familiar. From the factories, to the barren
environments, to the droves of people losing
themselves to the bittersweet oblivion of
technology, the game is full of connections
to the current state of our species. And piecing
together subtle worldbuilding details and
interviews with the game’s creators, it
seems that Scorn is indeed supposed to be
a future version of Earth, where the catastrophic
misuse of technology has left our species
unrecognizable. Ultimately, Scorn represents
a worst-case scenario for the story of humanity.
With all the potential this world has, I hope
the developers continue it in some form, and
show us more of their biomechanical vision...
As always, thanks for watching. If you enjoyed
this entry, please lend your support by liking,
subscribing, and hitting the notification
icon to stay up to date on all things Curious.
See you in the next video.